Charisma is the ability to attract and
influence others through charm
confidence and personal magnetism
while it is often described as a
mysterious quality that one either has
or doesn't have many experts believe
that the skills of charismatic people
can be learned and cultivated
here are a few tips to help you develop
charisma
be confident confidence is a key
component of charisma
believe in yourself and your abilities
and others will believe in you too
speak with conviction make eye contact
stand up straight and take your time in
space
being positive and optimistic a
charismatic person often exudes
positivity in optimism which can be
contagious
by focusing on the good in situations
and approaching challenges with a
positive attitude you can Inspire others
to do the same
be a good listener Charisma is not just
about talking it's also about listening
show genuine interest in what others
have to say and give them your full
attention
this will make them feel special in your
presence
be authentic charismatic people are
authentic and true to themselves
they don't try to be someone they're not
and they're comfortable in their own
skin which makes people trust them and
let their guard down
be empathetic Charisma also comes from
being able to connect with others on an
emotional level
show empathy and understanding towards
others and they will feel more
comfortable around you
be passionate charismatic people are
passionate about what they do and they
exude that passion in their words and
actions
show enthusiasm for your work and
interests and others will be drawn to
you
be a good communicator charismatic
people are skilled communicators
they know how to use words and Body
Language effectively to convey their
message and connect with others
being able to effectively communicate
your thoughts and ideas is crucial for
building charisma
be well informed and knowledgeable being
knowledgeable in diverse range of
subjects allows you to hold interesting
and engaging conversations and make
meaningful contributions
practice self-awareness it's important
to be aware of your own thoughts and
emotions and how they affect the way you
interact with others
by being self-aware you can better
understand how to present yourself in a
charismatic way
remember that Charisma is something that
will be developed over time with
practice and effort
be yourself be confident be passionate
and always keep learning
thank you for watching
subscribe for more